for Black History Month we are
celebrating trailblazers who became
leaders in their field and helped change
the course of history this morning we
hear from two civil rights attorneys
Fred gray was the lawyer for Rosa Parks
during the Montgomery bus boycott in
1955 and dr. Martin Luther King jr. an
Alabama native gray is now 89 years old
Benjamin Crump is a renowned attorney
known for representing the families of
the slain teenagers Trayvon Martin in
Florida and Michael Brown in Missouri
Crump who is 50 years old practices law
in five states and Washington DC Gray
has mentored Crump for more than 20
years we bought them together at the
Tuskegee History Center in Alabama to
talk about their life's work and paving
the way for countless others in the
modern civil rights movement well when I
was growing up in Montgomery and the
third is fathers Fisher's that were
basically only two possessions that
[Music]
african-american boys could really look
at as being professions that people
thought a lot about but we did have
teachers and preachers and I kind of
decided that I would probably try to be
both my father died when I was two my
mother was a domestic worker only went
to the fourth grade but she told the
five of us as we grew up in the west
side of Montgomery that we could be
anything we wanted to be if we did three
things one came Christ first in your
life
second stay in schools and got a good
education and three stay out of trouble
I tried to do all
in 1947 I enrolled in Alabama State
College for Negroes in Montgomery living
on the west side of town and the school
was on the east side of town so I used
the buses all the time for that purpose
by using the buses I observed that our
people were mistreated we were
frequently asked to get up and give our
seats to white persons and I observed
that everything was completely
segregated and we had a family friend
named edy Nixon who was a very
interested in civil rights and had been
president of the Montgomery chapter the
NAACP
he encouraged me to become a lawyer I
made a personal secret commitment in my
upper teen age that I was going to
finish law school come back to Alabama
take the bar exam become a lawyer and
destroy everything segregated I could
find
I wanted to be a lawyer ever since I was
in the fourth grade much like my mentor
Fred gray story is certain things that
trigger you to say you want to go be a
champion for justice and opponent to
enemies of equality and for me that was
when I was in the fourth grade
growing up in Lumberton North Carolina
our deliberate speed from the Supreme
Court decision and Brown didn't get to
Lumberton until around the late 70s and
so in 1979 I was in the fourth grade and
that's when they best black children
from South Flemington across the tracks
to the school in the white community
that was a newer school with newer books
and newer technology and all the black
children got free lunch and it would be
a long line of us waiting and a little
white children they could go get ala
carte lunches and they could get
cheeseburgers and Pete said french fries
everything that little children want and
I kept thinking to myself man why is it
that some people in certain parts of the
community have it so good
and others seem to have it so
challenging in my community and I
remember my mother told me it was
because of Brown versus the Board
Education and Thurgood Marshall and the
n-double-a-cp lawyers while we got to go
to the school with the new books and the
new technology and new equipment and I
said to myself I'm gonna be like they're
gonna march in the n-double-a-cp lawyers
when I grow up because I want to make it
better for people and my community
people who look like me and from that
day until this one that's what I've been
striving to do so I always knew that I
wanted to be a lawyer and fight for the
least of these as my grandmother's say
the people who need a voice the people
who are often marginalized
disenfranchised and dehumanized we are
amazed I am at your recall I mean I pray
Fred when I get to be 89 years old that
I can recall dates and facts like you're
doing that I mean well I didn't have the
privilege of going to enter integrated
anything yes sir and my whole idea was
to destroy segregation I started going
to the NAACP meetings and I met Rosa
Parks we would sit and share our lunches
and talk about the problems so on
December 1st it was like any other day
that we had talked we had our lunch came
back late in the evening and I had phone
calls from a whole lot of people and I
found out that miss parks had been
arrested
I went over she told me she wanted me to
represent her and I told I would but I
also told us several miss parks you know
we've been dealing with this problem on
the buses for a long time know
but you know there has been talk in the
community about people staying off of
the buses as a protest and if we're
gonna do that now is the time to make a
long story short went crosstown to join
robbing sums house and we sat in her
living room on the evening of December
1st in the morning of December 2nd and
made the plans for the Montgomery bus
boycott but then we said that we need to
have the preachers involved in it a
majority of the Negro citizens of
Montgomery Alabama have refrain from
riding city buses since December 5th
that's how dr. King was introduced and
then officially dr. King was made and
appointed the spokesman for the group
and the rest of it is history outrage
over the fatal shooting of
seventeen-year-old Trayvon Martin
protesters who are demanding the arrest
of that neighborhood watch captain I
think a lot went into the background of
people knowing about Trayvon Martin and
this kid who was walking home minding
his business when this neighborhood
watch volunteer with a 9-millimeter gun
profile pursued and shot him in the
heart two days later his father called
I cannot articulate this sound that was
coming from his voice this sound of
heart brokenness he said my son Trayvon
Martin
was walking home from the 7-eleven and
the neighborhood watch volunteer shot
and killed him there are two battles is
the bout in the court of law and about
in the court of public opinion no
justice and I understood that the only
way we were gonna win this bout in the
court of public opinion there's gonna be
with the young people in the young
energy and those young people who will
become black lives matter it was the
young people on social media who got
Trayvon Martin to mainstream media and
it was a lesson now that has been
duplicated dozens and dozens of times
since then
[Music]
frequently people will say well Fred
gray they say you did so much in the
silver rights movement I never did see
you out there marching I said that's
correct
I'm only moist for ceremonial reasons my
role was not to March my role was to get
the law and held the law protect the
individuals so they could March the
civil rights march consisted of people
doing a lot of things so I made speeches
some marched some did legal work but it
took all of it but it was because we
worked together and was able to do it
but the struggle continues our ways
marvel at what dr. King said when he
said we all have a role to play in the
struggle
[Music]
you